12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
avec moins de 370 milles habitants au
1er janvier 2018 soit dix sept mille
personnes de moins 105 ans c'est le
dernier recensement de la population qui
confirme des tendances observées ces
deux dernières décennies la martinique
vie un déclin démographique la
population vieillit le départ des jeunes
pour leur formation au prochain travail
ou pour vivre mieux ne faiblissent pas
le nombre de naissances rejoint presque
le nombre de décès voici le constant qui
provoque de l'inquiétude chez les
l'indifférencié d'autres mais des
questions chez tout le monde
bienvenue dans l'émission politique face
à la première demande donc la première
dont le thème est le déclin
démographique de la martinique causes
conséquences et solutions l'émission de
ce dimanche 21 février 2021 et réalisé
par cédric banques les épaules eric
toussaint je vous présente sans plus
tarder nos invités pendant le fam
éthique tout d'abord daniela pont
bonjour à la map en donjon à tous il est
bien connu de nos internautes et de zone
i auditeurs et auditrices un veau est
sociologue je le rappelle est vous avez
publié en mars 2019 dans le journal
progressiste l'article la martinique
vieillissante et des peuples est une
opportunité pour transformer nous aurons
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure je
signale que vous êtes la co directrice
de la publication d'un livre qui vient
d'arriver
édité aux éditions petra mobilité
émigration transaction éducative et
sociale puisque c'est l'un de vos
domaines de spécialités à fait à côté de
vous se trouve à christian louis joseph
bonjour et c'est louis joseph bonjour je
manque partie bien connu également de
zone aux auditrices et auditeurs et
internautes économistes et la dernière
tribune libre que vous avez fait
paraître sur ce thème
démographie de la martinique en 2020
chronique d'un désastre va nous
expliquer pourquoi ce titre disons non
seulement crocheur mais un peu
pessimiste et puis enfin notre dernier
invité et andré lucrèce mon jour mon
secret ce jour que nous connaissons
également parfaite massiot notre antenne
radio vous avez longtemps été
chroniqueur littéraire chez vous vous
êtes sociologue et écrivain autour d'une
quinzaine d'essais et de romans
et vous avez fait paraître également que
minime il ya quelques semaines
martinique décroissance démographique
les vraies raisons
un texte dans laquelle vous mettez un
certain nombre d'idées en avant et vous
faites pièce à d un certain nombre de
dix ont de mauvaises informations qui
circulent sur cette question et je
signale que votre dernier livre paru en
2019 antilles les paroles les visages et
les masques extrêmement intéressant à
lire puisque vous jeter on regarde comme
d'habitude sans complaisance sur
l'évolution ou la dévolution gêne c'est
notre société à madame monsieur tout
d'abord avant de commencer juste il ya
quelques semaines le 3 février c'était
le 10e anniversaire de la disparition
d'edouard glissant
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
personnellement retenu de son oeuvre et
son parcours
qu'est ce que vous a inspiré qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé gagner l'apport
que edouard glissant a posé la question
justement de la migration et de ce tout
le monde
comment la question de l'identité
elle elle n'est pas figée à bouter sur
des éléments à un moment donné qui ne
bouge plus mais cet inter relations qui
nous met face au monde qui nous fait en
fait modifier enrichir
réinterrogée ce que nous sommes à un
moment un instant t et 7 interrelations
ce tout le monde cette ouverture juste
donne cet enrichissement et puis cette
grande tolérance l'acceptation de
l'autre dans sa différence le droit à la
différence et le droit d'être au monde
vous dit je n'ai pratiquement rien à
ajouter sauf peut-être qu'on veut dire
qu'il ya une cinquantaine d'années
j'ai fait partie du groupe je travaille
à l'ime les sites uniques et d'études
créée par edouard glissant j'ai
participé au goût à commun qu'ils
avaient qu'il avait fondé et le dernier
souvenir ému que j'ai de lui ça remonte
à peut-être avant 30 ans je le revoyais
après des années il venait de publier
malmo quelque chose de ce genre
et jeudi c'est un peu difficile edwards
qui devrait faire attention petit lit
et il m'a répondu je vais pas passer mon
temps à descendre au peuple il faut
qu'ils peuvent façonner faut pour
remonter jusqu'à moi si vous pouvez vous
rapprocher des micro projets
d'intervention ça arrangerait notre
réalisateur ayant fait un truc facebook
avait écrit vous avez analysé le oui
semble donc je n'ai connu depuis très
très longtemps
d'ailleurs si dacoma que j'ai donné mon
premier article
c'était précisément une analyse du
phénomène de la négritude
précisons qu'à commencer le nom de la
revue qu'avait font des affaires
tout à fait et c'est alain kauffmann
numéro 2 1 parce que là la revue a
disparu aujourd'hui
alors je ne peux pas ne pas évoquer la
critique
justement dans le livre que vous vous
même vous avez évoqué anti les paroles
les visages et les masques
la critique que j'ai adressé à edouard
glissant
edwards est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement porté sur l'esthétique et ça
elle est réussie d'ailleurs mais c'est
aussi quelqu'un qui prend quelques
quelques quelques aises
je dirais avec et la conceptualisation
des choses et j'ai porté une critique
effectivement sur notamment sur cette
espèce de bévues qu'edouard a conçu qui
s'appelait le migrant nu bon alors je
raconte ça parce que beaucoup de gens le
savent et on a en martinique souvent
tendance à trop combats de coqs 10 à 1
mais quelqu'un lot vous avez donné à
edouard glissant et je répondais à cette
personne qui me disait ça joue il disait
mais ce que vous avez vu
venant la partie poétique livre géant du
nommage extrêmement vertueux à edouard
glissant
parce que je considère que glissant est
un immense poète malheureusement évolué
dans l'ombre un peu de d'aimé césaire
mais c'est un c'est une très très grand
poète
puis les voit que ces essais ont
peut-être pris le pas sur sa poésie sa
création artistique propre
oui parce que c'est ce que je dois pas
c'est à dire que l'esthétique toutes les
choses absolument merveilleuse la preuve
ce que je lui rends hommage mais
évidemment quand on écrit des essais il
faut être un petit peu plus rigoureux
qu'à que l'a été et doit un livre de
glissant que vous conservez un parmi ses
poèmes les indes je suppose à leysin
extraordinaire des indes extraordinaire
et je vais d'ailleurs cessé c'est
curieux que ce que vous en parliez parce
que récemment il ya un jeune
martiniquais qui me disait tu sais gp
j'ai perdu ma soeur mais c'était une
amoureuse d'edward dix ans et on me dit
qu'il faudra que je je je je donne un
poème le jour donc de l'enterrement
il me dit qu'est ce que tu me proposes
je lui dis d and d inde
comme quoi alors justement et de
l'ambition quand vous citez le christ
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir plus
talent qui dénonçait en 1963 donc comme
on le rappeler comme vous le dites pour
ceux qui ne savaient pas cette politique
d'immigration voulue par le gouvernement
planifiée à l'intérieur du binôme mais
avant d'arriver jusque là je voudrais
juste rappeler deux ou trois chiffres
avant d'expliquer est-ce que l'on peut
parler ou pas de déclin démographique
j'ai fait que ce soit un d'avancé titre
un peu provocateur c'est en temps parle
plus d'eux des quizz ou bien de reflux
ou de transition démographique nous nous
entendrons sur les mots tout à l'heure
mais juste pour rappeler qu'il y
v selon l'insee au 1er janvier 2018
année il ya trois en arrière 368 1783
personnes habitant la martinique
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure alors
déjà comment ça fait 6 ou 10 ans une
expression 2002 et 2010 à 2019 ça fait
quasiment trente quatre mille personnes
de moi ça n'est pas rien comme vous
dites que joseph s'est quasiment 10% de
la population de moi c'est déjà une
première explication technique si
quelqu'un a la réponse pourquoi chaque
fois l'hymne sindone des chiffres aussi
un portable trois ans de décalage dans
l'autre est-ce que ça n'est pas déjà
dépassé au moment où nous avons les
chiffres par rapport à une réalité qui
n'existe plus par définition c'est tout
à fait normal
les techniques de recensement de l'insee
ont changé un autre fois jusqu'à 99 vous
avez d'érotisme exhaustive tous les cinq
ou six ans depuis les choses ont changé
il y à un recensement exhaustif des
communes de grigny l'habitant et des
enquêtes qui sont menées sur une période
de cinq ans dans les communes de 10000
habitants et plus et bien entendu dans
tout ce site exploité annuellement les
chiffres sont corrigés mais comprenez
bien que l'ours comme ils devront donc
prendre les chiffres de 2010 est
actualisé le temps de sortir toutes les
données de les mettre en forme données
et de les publier
il se passe bien deux ou trois ans cela
dit il n'empêche que entre temps l'insee
vous donne régulièrement des estimations
de la population pour chacun sait déjà
me relis une estimation de la population
au 1er janvier 2021 alors qu'en passant
par leur sens maintenant dans la
définition démographique même comment
fait tampon contes et légendes dans un
pays en particulier en france des taux
ont formé des de nombreux mois et
exhaustive pour les petites communes et
on fait des enquêtes qui sont traités
statistiquement est qui qui donne des
résultats tout à fait conforme pour
autant qu'on puisse en juger à ce qui se
passe réellement
alors les chiffres que nous donnons et
l'évolution sur 20 30 40 voire 50 ans
bon train vieillissement continue de la
population c'est à dire que la
population
quand on dit que la population vieillit
stade et que les gens vivent il ya de
plus en plus de personnes qui vivent de
plus en plus âgées mais en même temps il
y à une baisse considérable du nombre de
personnes jeunes soient les moins de 35
ans par les modérés temps ça dépend de
la manière dont on est content et qui
peut s'expliquer de différentes manières
et vous crucial joseph audit de l'an
dernier bien que vous avez publié que ce
phénomène suisse écho à ce point grave
que le jogo citant la gravité du
problème ne doit pas se mesurer à la
baisse de la population ni à
l'augmentation du poids relatif de sa
fraction la plus âgée véritable problème
est là signé effecté sur la préfecture
sur la partie la plus jeune de la
population du fait de l'immigration et
de la baisse de la natalité
quand vous dites que c'est grave ça veut
dire que vous êtes inquiet par cette
situation tout à fait parce à lysiane
zygo lorsqu'on dit que deux en 10 ans
2010-2019 la martinique a perdu 34 mille
habitants sur les chiffres qui est
important mais ce qui est derrière est
beaucoup plus grave
c'est à dire que la martinique a perdu
environ 60 milles jeunes de personnes de
moins de 50 ans et elle en a gagné 30 et
quelques milles de plus de ces craintes
en c'est le solde
la différence entre les équipes de 30000
mais ce qui à mon avis est extrêmement
grave c'est la saignée la disparition de
cette populaire de cette partie jeunes
de la population il faut bien comprendre
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
refuse que presque à caractériser la
situation démographique de notre ville
comme vieillissement je serais plutôt
tenté de parler de dépopulation que le
vieillissement les kazakhs et analyse
chaque pièce mais enfin il faut dire
aussi qu'il y à côté donc de cette
déperdition des jeunes a également un
vieillissement donc
mais mais mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont
insisté là dessus c'est dramatique c'est
dramatique
tous pays se construit avec sa jeunesse
tout pays se construit avec sa jeunesse
et j'en profite pour dire quelque chose
ce phénomène n'est pas propre à nous
mêmes d'abord il existe dans la caraïbe
un peu moins un peu moins mais on peut
expliquer pourquoi la guadeloupe c'est
quasiment la même situation légèrement
légèrement moins mais à peu près la même
situation
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que dans
le monde entier ce phénomène existe et
on croirait qu'un certain nombre de pays
comme par exemple la grèce l'italie le
web
la suède la suisse d'autant corps et
sont des pays qui qui qui pleure en
quelque sorte tu as vraiment la
disparition de leur jeunesse d'allemagne
l'allemagne aussi mais l'allemagne
depuis très longtemps dont un tel
déficit que l'allemagne ouvre ses
frontières justement aux migrants et
c'est donc donc il faut il faut dire ça
à nos auditeurs
ce n'est pas un phénomène qui soit qui
est propre à la martinique c'est un
phénomène que le monde entier
la particulier l'asie du sud est aussi
le monde antique la chine la chine la
chine qui limite est justement un donc
les naissances et mais la chine se
retrouve justement à voir sa population
donc vieille beaucoup plus importante
que la population jeune pour que la
chine elle marche avec 1 milliard 300
millions
bien sûr on peut voir sur bien sûr mais
c'est quand même un phénomène phénomène
mondial mondiale oui daniel à porec et
quelques observations sans sursaut
vieillissement sur la déperdition des
jeunes crucial joseph état d'un certain
nombre de chiffres dans son analyse qui
aurait vinci ou deux pages avec 1
théo graphique il faut s'accrocher parce
que là ça ça ça peut créer des frissons
quand on le lit comme ça à froid quand
vous dites que depuis 2010 les 50 ha et
moi c'est donc les jeunes dont certains
de nos hommes a diminué de 70 mille
personnes et qu'en même temps le nombre
de personnes âgées a augmenté de 35
mille et en 2020 si ces personnes âgées
représentent 49% de la population n
était qu 22 bon sens c'est-à-dire deux
fois moins soit une immense en 1999 en
l'espace de 2 10 ans de trente ans plus
tôt on a doublement de la proportion la
plus âgée de la population ils savent de
quoi ça a de quoi inquiéter daniela port
oui nous sommes je crois que les pays
andré lucrèce l'a dit et j'allais le
dire donc il a anticipé en sautant de
connaître
nous sommes en train d'arriver à une à
la croisée de politiques diverses qui
ont été menées ici ou là sur la maîtrise
des naissances famille etc et qui
produit ce que nous avons aujourd'hui
mais la martinique
en plus de ça a une histoire il ya une
histoire qui fait que nous arrivons à
une situation de dépeuplement et de
vieillissement comme je les dis dans
dans l'article que j'ai écrit c'est les
deux à la fois et 7 cette dynamique loin
c'est vrai que chaque fois on fait le
point sur les chiffres et cetera
je crois qu'il nous faut dépasser ça et
moi je ne prends pas ça comme quelque
chose de dramatique oui ok c'est un
constat maintenant qu'est ce que nous
faisons comment pensons-nous les choses
pour que le pays puisse repartir trouver
une dynamique s des poètes est ce qu'on
va mener des politiques partiel sur
cette question fait revenir et cetera
est ce que c'est ça ou est-ce que c'est
plus une grande politique pensée public
de 2 pour la martinique d'une manière
générale et puis qu'est ce que l'on veut
comme population est-ce que dé
martinique aux martiniquais
de par le monde qui doivent rentrer ou
est ce que nous devons préparer cette
martinique à être parce qu' edouard
glissant c'est tout le monde très bien
vous anticipez sur le débat nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
je vous le promets c'est pas une
promesse 2 comme on y prend l'air mais
revenons si vous les causes réelles de
cette évolution démographique depuis
trente ou quarante ans andré lucrèce je
ne veux pas vous citer puisque vous même
vous êtes là vous pouvez nous expliquer
vous expliquer que dans au début des
années 1960 ce que nous savons tous que
le but me nomme le bureau des migrations
intéressant les originaires de
départements d'outre-mer une agence
gouvernementale placée sous le contrôle
du ministère de l'intérieur et celui des
dom tom à l'instigation de michel debré
alors au député de la réunion et pour le
ministre à organiser les migrations vers
la france continentale de jeunes de
moins de 35 ans venant essentiellement
de la réunion de la martinique et de la
guadeloupe au point que même si on a
qu'on a commencé à avoir au bout d'une
vingtaine d'années les effets sur les
pays natif sur les pays exportateurs sur
le territoire action entre acteurs de
cette émigration les effets néfastes qui
commençait est ce que vous pouvez
insister un peu si on sait qu'après le
bibendum ce qu'il a contribué en tant
que comme saignée démographique
écoutez d'abord il faut il faut
comprendre pourquoi
mais le demi d'hommes intégré à cette
époque dans les années 60
nous avons une population de la
martinique avec une pléthore de jeunes
55% sa population en martinique à moins
d'un an
à cette époque là et souvient un
événement historique important à mon
avis c'est décembre 59 redescendre 59 ap
va entamer une période de troubles et en
tout cas si la lecture qu'en fait le
gouvernement français d'abord il ya
trois jeunes martiniquais qui meurent
les jeunes martiniquais sont dans la rue
il lance des pierres exister rail se
révoltent
ça attire l'attention du de de la france
au sein du gouvernement français
il y à une atmosphère à la martinique
qui se développe et qui n'est pas
étonnante parce que on est dans une
situation internationale un peu
bouillonnante
je vous rappelle que c'est la révolution
cubaine est en marche
ya la guerre d'algérie où un certain
nombre de martiniquais notre refuse de
prendre les armes contre les algériens
et puis il ya aussi donc la naissance
des velléités en tout cas d'indépendance
africaine et donc il ya là quelque chose
qui qui bouillonne et ce dans ce
bouillonnement la gauche
à travers ces partis me dirige une fait
intervenir la notion d'autonomie
ils allaient les choses deviennent un
peu plus concrète ça veut dire que pour
le gouvernement français il ya des gens
qui cherchent à se séparer donc de la
métropole il s'agit du parti communiste
et du parti progressiste d'aimé césaire
convenait des prix est d'ailleurs en 58
et donc tout ça fait que le gouvernement
français dit il faut faire quelque chose
alors il ya un élément que je n'ai pas
donné
si la crise énorme de l'économie de
plantation qui fait que vous avez une
double comme un dirais-je un double
déplacement de populations qui va se
faire
d'une part des efforts de france c'est
là que vaincre et la ceinture populaire
de fort de france et est également donc
le départ enfonce donc est organisée par
le gouvernement français d'abord parce
que il a besoin de main d'oeuvre à ce
moment là c'est pas la situation
d'aujourd'hui un vent la france est
demandeuse de mende menace à l'heure
dans quel domaine dans quel secteur
d'activité tout de tous les secteurs on
n'est pas loin
on est en train de reconstruire après la
guerre là et les alors les c'est vrai
que les martiniquais on sont allées et
les antillais d'une manière générale
chutent dans des nous espace
professionnel est typé c'est évidemment
les hôpitaux c'est beaucoup beaucoup
aussi dans la ratp dans la police dans
la police parce que jusqu'à maintenant
il y en a dix un glee se rappelle qu'
ceux qui lui sont revenus à la
martinique pour donc leur retraite mais
vous avez une série de policiers et
donne la poste et la poste bien entendu
ce qu'est la poste que ce ne sont pas
des emplois les plus qualifiés que les
antilles et oui lyonnais occupe et aux
france bien entendu bien entendu et
c'est ça qui change aujourd'hui on va le
voir tout à l'heure les gens qui partent
aujourd'hui on dit très précieusement
oui c'est à cause donc du fait qu'il ya
pas de travail mais c'est pas aussi
simple que ça c'est pas aussi simple que
çà et là la chose la plus grave beau
c'est la parole aux autres la chose la
plus grave c'est que le ces gens qui
partent sont des jeunes
c'est à dire des personnes en âge de
procréer et donc ça a une incidence bien
entendu sur la population antillaise
aujourd'hui juste ajouter quelque chose
à propos de ce que disait qu ici on tout
à l'heure où le vieillissement
le problème c'est que christian en fait
on s'étire est ce effectivement surtout
donc à 7
ce départ des jeunes mais en même temps
la matinée camille caractéristiques et
les 38e dans le monde ou au sens de ce
qu'on appelle idh indice de
développement humain de placer haut
placés dans le cas bien sûr bien placé
et en particulier à cause précisément de
la santé des martiniquais c'est
paradoxal parce qu'en même temps on
subit le chlordécone avec une pléthore
de deux maladies qui y sont liés mais en
même temps l'espérance de vie est très
convenable quand une monnaie notamment
les femmes par exemple ne passerez pas
seuls 80 ans par exemple
1 les hommes se sont pas très loin même
s'ils sont en deçà de sa et donc c'est
ça le vieillissement qui se fait en même
temps
et qui est caractéristique aussi de
notre population
alors christian news est justement le
binôme montrent que l'immigration
d'ivanka duré 20 ans le officiellement
le vignoble était démontée en 1992 donc
après 20 ans je ne dirais pas de bons et
loyaux services dizaine d'activités et
qui a été remplacé ensuite par l' agence
nationale de la tnt pour la
transitionnelle d'hommes qui est un site
qui devenir dom et avec d'autres
vocations
ce n'était plus les migrations massives
qui était recommandé vous êtes bien
d'accord
à partir de ce moment là dans les années
1963 jusqu'en 1982 on a eu des dizaines
de milliers de jeunes qui sont partis
qui n'ont pas été remplacés parce qu'ils
sont même parvenus et ça a créé ça a
contribué à la chute de la natalité est
donc au vieillissement de la population
oui alors laissez moi quand même revenir
tout petit peu si c'était le seuil
vieillissement je ne veux pas rassuré
les martiniquais je veux au contraire
les inquiéter dire que le phénomène du
vieillissement est un phénomène
universel un phénomène mondial
oui c'est vrai avec des progrès de la
médecine les gens vieillissent de plus
en plus comme en même temps la fécondité
baisse il ya de moins en moins d'enfants
beaucoup de pays ont des problèmes de
renouvellement des générations
sauf que comme des pays comme l'italie
comme la crise comme la france comme
l'allemagne le déficit qu'on peut avoir
représenterait plus de choses de la
population et le besoin de l'immigration
est relativement faible
ça peut se gérer assez facilement en
martinique des choses ont tâté un tel
degré qu'on peut penser qu'il ya un
changement de nature
certes il ya eu un allongement de
l'espérance de vie mais lorsque vous
prenez la baisse de la fécondité vous en
est au stade où vous avez un solde
naturel c'est-à-dire une excédent de
naissances sur les décès qui est
pratiquement de zéro ce n'est pas le cas
en grèce honnie falcon d'admettre du
panca le cas en italie c'est le cas
c'est le cas en belgique et vous avez
tel déficit de la population qu'il
faudrait imaginer une immigration et
nomme un 5000 personnes par an chaque
année qu'ils devraient venir ici pour
maintenir la population à son niveau
actuel
je crois qu'il faut y réfléchir c'est
extrêmement grave alors maintenant
parlons maintenant de la recherche des
responsabilités
je crois beaucoup
comme d'habitude nous sommes nous sommes
en martinique et il faut toujours des
responsables ne sont des victimes
permanentes
il faut toujours un responsable et on
cible le but ni donne il faut rappeler
andré l'aviez fait qu'à l'époque chute
de l'économie notation ça n'affecte pas
seulement la martinique ou la guadeloupe
ça affecte toute la caraïbe et il y à
une émigration spontanée dans toutes les
directions en particulier d'ailleurs la
république dominicaine par exemple le
sucre pourtant combien la cuba où les du
suspect faisait au début des années 50
aux souabes énormément de l'haïtien ou
deux jamaïcains la différence qu'il y a
entre eux la situation martiniquaise et
la situation de ces pays c'est que deux
côtés les gens partaient livrés à eux
mêmes en martinique il y a eu un
encadrement de cette émigration qui
existait déjà spontanément et qui compte
tenu de l'état de l'économie à l'époque
étaient appelés à confier à enfler enflé
donc moi j'ai tendance à dire même s'il
ya des aspects extrêmement négative à
l'organisation du binôme à son
fonctionnement peut-être j'ai donné à
dessus qu'il faut plutôt mettre au
crédit de l'état français d'avoir
cherché à encadrer cette émigration même
s'il n'a pas toujours bien fait alors
parlons maintenant de l'impact du
bibendum sur la démographie de rater les
caisses
oui il y a une fonction de jeunes en âge
de procréer seulement il ne faut pas
oublier que pendant que cette fonction
se faisait arriver sur le marché si
j'ose dire les générations nombreuses
nées dans les années 70 et le début des
années 60 qui étaient en âge de procréer
et en somme si la population est plus
diminuée elle n'a pas connu de dcl et le
dcl et d'aujourd'hui n'est pas les plus
tableau b mais deux roues lorsque vous
prenez des des pyramides day2 89 97 des
dix années suivantes
il n'y a pas de problème particulier ce
sont des pyramides qui sont relativement
équilibrés les migrations d'ailleurs je
le dis de 89 à 2005 à peu près était
inférieur vers ce n'est pas
l'immigration parce que je le répète
c'est un solde il ya ceux qui hantent et
ce qui saute
et parmi ces alors on pourra discuter de
la thèse du remplacement etc etc
disons que le déficit de population
jusqu'à 2005 est inférieur à 1000
personnes de même à 800 personnes par an
c'est à partir de 2005 2006 quelque
chose il ya un boom de 2,2 de
l'immigration et en même temps
d'ailleurs que le chômage se développe
ce talent y est en fait ces années-là
signe l'échec de la politique de
développement qui a été mise en place en
particulier en particulier de l'île
depuis une quinzaine d'années daniela
pense sauf si on démantèle
administration de christian joseph on
assiste à ce phénomène particulier on a
beaucoup plus de personnes qui s'en vont
que des personnes qui vont entrer parmi
celles qui s'en vont il ne il ou elle ne
reviennent pas parce que ce sont souvent
des personnes jeunes hommes en 35 ans
qui vont travailler qui vont se former
et qu'ils ne reviennent pas
nécessairement ou allant déjà qu'ils
sont bien formés qui travaillent même
ici qui sont au chômage nés qui
travaillent et qui s'en vante parce que
mais c'est plus compliqué c'est plus
difficile de vivre et on a des
opportunités supérieur à l'extérieur
mais ça ce n'est plus un phénomène
purement j'allais dire démographique
c'est un problème beaucoup plus complexe
beaucoup plus sociologique c'est une
idée moi je crois que les flux arrivée
partir c'est c'est quelque chose c'est
un élément je peux des naturelles à
toutes les sociétés des gens bougent une
soie à bout des raisons de survie parce
qu'ils ont besoin de manger boire ou
encore recherche un mieux être dans la
société dans la psi aujourd'hui nous
avons beaucoup de des faits beaucoup je
suis plutôt réservé sur ces chiffres
beaucoup de personnes partirait et c'est
bon si nous avons maintenant ce flux de
départs il faut s'interroger sur ce que
propose la structure économique
aujourd'hui en martinique quelques ll la
structuration de nos activités
est-ce que les formations que les jeunes
sont partis faire dans des universités
hors de la martinique
quand ces jeunes rentrent est-ce que ce
qui est proposé économiquement
correspond à leur profil et leurs
aspirations
alors oui donc où il se décale if i en
rentrant pays
et puis en prenant ce qu'il y a et si
c'est bien ou encore il décide de
repartir
ou vraiment exprimer leur leur savoir en
fait c'est un potentiel quoi voilà est
plus que ce faire cette espèce de focale
sur les ces flux il nous faut un moment
donné nous réinterroger sur la
structuration économique le choix de
société pour le pays martinique c'est
moi je le dis souvent
ok il y a quelque chose qui se passe
mais regardons ici qu'est ce que nous
proposons aux jeunes et nous on va en
reparler
tout à l'heure sur le les orientations
de l'université des antilles mhz alors
le chanteur revenir vers andré lucrèce
qui dit que tout à l'heure vous avez dit
ce que ce que vous avez écrit dans votre
texte
kubina temps savoir que ce n'est pas
tant le chômage des jeunes qui est la
cause principale ou évidente de leur
départ ou leur manque de formation mais
il ya également d'autres
une autre cause qui est simplement le
fait qu' on en a un peu assez que l'on
soit jeune ou pas d'ailleurs
face à nos difficultés quotidiennes de
vie que ce soit l'accès au logement les
problèmes du transport ont l'accès à
l'eau à la formation universitaire à la
petite connaissance aux débouchés
professionnels aux relations sociales
trop facilement conflictuelle je vous
cite donc comme quoi il n'ya pas une
seule cause du départ des 21 50 c'est
pluriel tout à fait j'en arrive à ce qui
vient d'être évoqué l'apport en réalité
rif
il faut savoir un que cette d'abord je
réfléchis soulève la question des jeunes
depuis très longtemps j'ai fui en 95
1995 un texte qui a paru dans le monde
diplomatique qui s'appelle de jeunes
angoisses d'une vie tromperie et là en
plus j'ai été relancé par des
institutions qui voudrait que je
travaille justement sur le problème de
la jeunesse en particulier le problème
du départ des jeunes
et c'est ça qui m'a un peu poussé nos
coeurs donné une première synthèse yeux
le problème c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui une société que l'on dit
dystopique faisant évidemment le
contraire de l'utopie qui serait donc la
société idéale avec une société dans
laquelle il est difficile de vivre et
pour moi c'est pour ça que je dis dans
mon texte je parle du métier de vivre
c'est quand les ces jeunes-là réfléchi
précisément leur métier de vivre dans
lequel ils vont entrer là qui sont par
exemple étudiants tout simplement
lycéens et qu'il est qu'il voit donc et
qu'ils vivent dans cette seule ce site
société difficile et bien entendu ils
sont orientés vers l'extérieur
cet extérieur alors il est évidemment
pratiquement à 80 85% vers l'europe
mais n'oubliez pas qu'il ya aussi des
jeunes qui sont attirés par exemple par
le canada les états-unis et c'est là
qu'arrive et donc est donc ce que ce que
je veux souligner c'est que le réflexe
pavlovien à la limite qui dit que
puisque les jeunes par c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas de travail ça n'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas seulement ça je ne dis pas
qu'il n'ya pas ça évidemment puisque je
pense qu'elle lit a chez les jeunes une
appétence de vie qui fait que cette
appétence de vie n'est pas justement
satisfaite dans un mythe dans une
société comme la nôtre je vous donner
deux exemples on pousse notamment pour
nos auditeurs des exemples concrets
moi pendant six mois hr sur le
territoire de schoelcher aussi bien les
étudiants les lycéens n'avaient pas de
moyens de se déplacer au point que le
maire a dû mettre en place une système
donc lui et j en quelque sorte dé facto
pour donner justement assez à ses élèves
qu'ils avaient le choix entre quoi faire
du stop ou aller à pied au lycée on
appris à aller du tout ou ne pas y aller
du tout bon certes alors ne pas y aller
du tout je joue une parenthèse parce que
en ce qui concerne les vieux ça a été
aussi dramatique
vous avez des gens qui par exemple que
j'ai entendus quasiment pleut et donc à
la radio martinique pourrait bien
d'ailleurs un petit 10 m
j'attendais depuis dix mois rendez-vous
ophtalmologiques ou pour mon épouse
quand je je je veux donc l'amener matin
un chez son ophtalmologue
il se trouve que je n'ai pas de moyen de
circulation
voyez ce sont des choses extrêmement
vite à ce sont des choses vitales
s'établit et essai et c'est ce monsieur
qui racontait 16
ces faits étaient quasiment au bord des
larmes parce que vous savez bien que
préfecture aujourd'hui à la martinique
ces dix mois un an un rendez vous tamo
logique ça c'est le premier exemple le
deuxième exemple ça a été évoqué par
madame la porte s'il est blessé notre
université
notre université aujourd'hui et elle est
en dégénérescence il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont vous avez à
la fois des conflits entre les deux
pôles universitaires mais vous avez
aussi une université qui ne vit pas moi
quand j'ai enseigné à l'université il ya
très longtemps
il ya nous avions une conférence nous
donnions de conférences chaque jeudi
ça s'appelait dès jeudi chaque jeudi les
jeunes avaient de quoi re d écouter des
débats des terrasses ou des thèmes bien
entendu qu'ils quittent ailier donc à
eau à l'université et ça ça n'existe
plus dont vous avez universités qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas apéritif vue
pour rester d'un doigt et l'idée de
l'appétence et donc et ils ont autant eu
finalement un très grand appétit de
connaissances mais vous ne trouvez pas
ça sur notre site et dans d'autres
universités et donc par conséquent vous
lister où ces phénomènes font que cette
vie devient dystopique c'est à dire
extrêmement difficile vous vous dites
qu'on mais est-ce qu ailleurs c'est
autrement et ils répondent oui
ailleurs c'est autrement parce que
l'herbe est toujours plus verte ailleurs
bien entendu face à la première
j'en à partie
l'herbe est toujours plus verte ailleurs
dit vous daniel abord mais c'est vrai
aussi parfois parfois se fait des
illusions
et puis quand on va vivre justement
cette ces termes que l'on croyait verte
elle devient jaunâtre et parfois très
piquante et on retourne au pays
alors attendez juste un chiffre 1 pour
na pas abonné au journal
on a donné beaucoup de démission l'insee
a montré alors déjà un peu les traits
cite une étude réalisée par an 30 notre
compte parce qu'il ya trop de ballons
temarii qui disait que 42% des jeunes
ayant un emploi résider en france
dean serment a fait une étude publiée en
2010 9 qui montre que la moitié des
jeunes antillais notting hill ou pire
demain 35 ans qui ont un diplôme à
niveau bac +2 et au delà vivent en
france
ça veut dire bien ce que ça veut dire et
quand nous avons six jeunes lorsque la
risée ici au chômage
et bien quand les jeunes quand il y en a
huit sur dix qui travaillent donc ça
veut bien dire aussi que l'air peut être
beaucoup plus verte ailleurs louis
l'herbe est certainement plus verte
ailleurs puisque nous avons quand même
beaucoup de jeunes martiniquais qui
évolue ailleurs qui travaille donc en
quelque part ils ont trouvé un espace
mais c'est bien ce que je disais tout à
l'heure on revient à quoi on revient à
un tissu économique en martinique qui
est déprimé il est certes des prix mais
d'une manière générale en france et
cetera mais il est temps du fait qu' il
y a un certain nombre d'initiatives et
puis une dynamique mais en martinique
nous sommes sur un espace qui est ce
qu'il est avec une orientation
économique qui produit peu de valeur
ajoutée
sinon une valeur ajoutée qui est exogène
cette valeur ajoutée elle n'est pas
franchement à 80% pour notre territoire
donc comment voulez vous que nous ayons
des emplois nous ayons ce qu'il faut
pour que les jeunes martiniquais puisse
résider en martinique vivre de 2 en
martinique
donc je crois que plus qu'à réfléchir à
d
dispositif parcellaires sur cette
question kiki aujourd'hui que l'on voit
certaines personnes portent des
dispositifs veut faire venir et tout ça
c'est une vue partielle de la question
il nous faut aujourd'hui et là on va
rentrer dans des processus de campagne
et cetera puisqu'il ya eu une élection
en juin qui s'amène pour une
collectivité majeur il faut de vrais
programmes du de de dax fort pour
justement regénérer cette société
martiniquaise afin que nous fassions
revenir quelques-uns à fait que nous
retenions ceux qui sont là et qui ont
envie de partir d'aller trouver une
herbe rendons notre herbe verte apprécié
le joseph total à ou disiez qu'il faut
vraiment réfléchir à la manière de faire
revenir ceux qui sont partis quels que
soient leur âge leur formation ou
dissuader ceux qui s'en sentent obligés
de partir qu'est-ce qu'elle pistes de
réflexion avant nous parce que quand
nous entendons les discours politiques
enfin le discours des responsables
politiques qu'ils soient élus ou pas on
a l'impression d'un grand classicisme et
il ya peu d'innovations dans leur vision
dans leur programme pour justement
développer autrement la martinique tels
que telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
je ne crois pas avoir dit qu'il fallait
faire revenir ceux qui sont partis parce
que je ne crois pas tellement à cette
solution là même si ça peut être
toujours intéressant mais c'est là se
pose de poulains de l'attractivité de
vous parler en des eaux de parler daniel
tout à l'heure on va on va y revenir et
pts et une chose me gêne énormément et
l'encore andré parler de diversité
je suis stupéfait de voir que nous avons
ici faculté de sciences économiques de
droit je n'ai pas vu sortir de cette
université un seul texte sur les
problèmes actuels de la société de la
martinique
je n'ai pas vu non plus d'ailleurs nous
nous restons sa politique soucier de
connaître le phénomène démographique en
martinique
pourquoi les gens par le dialogue la
question a été soulevée la prendrait
également par daniel moi je serais tenté
de dire qu'il faudrait peut-être une
approche très différenciée des
motivations de
départ parce que lorsque je l'insee nous
dit que demain indiqué sur cinq éprouve
des privations ci vers le mois de vie
socialement économique d'ailleurs je ne
suis pas persuadé que les petits jeunes
qui à bab appartiennent à ce milieu soit
des gens qui fréquentent l'université
soit des gens qui est des frustrations
parce qu'ils n'ont pas suffisamment de
concert je pense que le problème est
peut-être de trouver du travail mais je
crois qu'on ne pourra finalement parlé
très clairement si on n'a pas le la base
de connaissances utiles et ça nous
manque ça nous un terrible mais je crois
bien il ya un gros effort a fait il est
urgent qu'on mette en place des états
faisant appel notamment claude valentin
mari qui s'occupa linley de tout ce
qu'il faut c'est des autres mais a
terminé 10e qui depuis une douzaine
d'années nous avait alerté sur ce ce
déclin démographique qui datent de
l'aude et paix de 2007 le déclin
démographique la population avait
continué à croître jusqu'en et jusqu'en
2006 ils nous avaient alertés sur ça
mais personne n'a jamais rien fait on a
tendance à ne se préoccuper que de
l'immédiat et à s'installer dans une
sorte de normalité au s'habitue à ce que
la population diminue sans réfléchir aux
conséquences gravissimes de cette
situation par le démange a feeling c'est
républicain études en 1990 après le
recensement disant que si les tendances
démographiques actuelles qu'en 1990 se
confirmait la martinique aurait pu avoir
environ 1 700 mille habitants en 2030
mission loin du lot l'appui de christian
et est excessif en disant qu aucun
politique ne s'est penché sur sa wii
parce que quelques initiés il ya quand
même des initiatives car le virus
consorts pour dire eh oui il ya quand
même
lorsqu'un conseil régional sous le siège
de chimie a quand même sur la base de
ces éléments là il y avait quand même eu
un petit un observatoire qui avait été
criés à côté du conseil régional c'était
monsieur papa rajpal à georges paroles
de l'hymne c'est quand même le
secrétaire de l'association le trésorier
benjamin comment tu peux oublier ça donc
c'est petit mais il y avait quand même
fait il ya un travail sur cela et c'est
comme ça que le dispositif régional
migration retour à jets étaient mis en
place un kit qui consistait non pas
faire venir des jeunes pour intégrer des
entreprises des impôts existants mais
des jeunes avec un projet de création
d'entreprise ou étaient pris en charge
pendant pendant deux trois ans un
salaire une maison et cetera leur
permettant de trouver comment je peux 10
adultes du mou financiers pour pouvoir
lancer leur affaire solution qu'ont
souhaité comme iman et bwin com mais
après on peut on peut discuter de ça on
peut le discuter en jeu au pied du lit à
l'initiative young lion mais je crois
qu'on doit aller beaucoup plus loin que
ses auteurs beaucoup plus loin et
réinterrogé des cadres alors un parle
des solutions andré lucrèce il y as
parmi les solutions bon les difficultés
qu on compte faire magnon revenir des
personnes individuellement mais il y à
la lime innovation donc il ya quelques
notions qui disque mais pourquoi ne pas
ouvrir les vannes de l'immigration faire
appel aux apens de main d'oeuvre où de
jeunes personnes qui vont finir par
s'installer faire des enfants qui vont
eux mêmes la génération si votre devenir
des martiniquaises des martiniquais et
sa part contribué à redonner du souffle
redynamiser le pays leur peuple et q
pourquoi pas partie aussi de nouveaux
rei est ce que vous acquiescez à ce
genre de cette douleur
je voudrais revenir sur eux je répondrai
à cette question je voudrais revenir à
ce qui vient d'être dit
je pense que en même temps il y à une
évolution de la mentalité de nos jeunes
je veux dire qu'à un moment donné
notamment être que même dans ma
génération
finalement le travail recherché était
essentiellement un travail de
fonctionnaire aujourd'hui vous avez des
initiatives qui sont ils sont légion je
si je prends par exemple moi j'ai trois
fils n'y a aucun qui qu'ils soient
fonctionnaires sous tous les toits donc
dans dans pression libérale ou
[Musique]
provisionné junior etc
je regarde autour d'eux leurs amis aussi
commun la même sensation même génération
et même orientation donc ce qui veut
dire
et j'ajoute à cela d'une manière
générale d'abord il faudrait préciser
une chose c'est qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons des classes
par à toi aux grandes écoles ce qui est
nous et nous produisons la d'aider des
gens qui vont justement dans ces grandes
écoles le problème simplement c'est que
leur activité professionnelle c'est pas
une activité professionnelle qui a lieu
ici exactement pourquoi on construit pas
je passe en particulier un bénéfice
on ne construit pas ici ni d'avion ni de
sous marins ni quoi que ce soit de ce
genre pas encore encore moins de encore
pas encore pas en toi donc en tout cas
un changement de mentalité considérable
et à côté de cela
à côté des grandes écoles etc vous avez
aussi des initiatives vous avez plein de
jeunes qui décident de ne fonder leur
leur entreprise et ça je trouve que
c'est tout un changement considérable
dont il faudra tenir compte alors les
migrations pour des migrations
si je puis dire ça a été une proposition
donc
j'ai lu avec intérêt
c'est donc gerry l'étang un cac iliad
qui a proposé sa et qui propose un
particulier une immigration haïtienne
alors pour plusieurs raisons il dit
d'abord parce que c'est ce sont des
personnes qui sont des ce sont des
travailleurs considérable et
deuxièmement ils sont créolophones et
ils sont aussi francophone quelquefois
donc ça c'est la proposition de gerry
l'étang
il faut y réfléchir hariti qu'un pays
d'émigration de beaucoup d'haïtiens
vivent à l'extérieur ils vivent à
l'extérieur même si nous n'avons pas eu
un certain nombre d'eux comme dirais-je
d'exactions telles que ça se passe en
guadeloupe où il ya eu des pogroms anti
haïtien
je crains que si l'on fait par exemple
référendum là dessus on pose la question
à la population martiniquaise
je ne suis pas sûr que ce sera accepté
facilement
même s'il s'agit d'une émigration j'ai
envie de dire choisir et jose en alliés
en cas l'organiser et en même temps
limité et en même temps limité et donc
j'en ai discuté avec gerry qui m'a
appelé d'ailleurs lorsqu'il avait
justement ce le papier que j'avais fait
on savait pas que tous les deux on
écrivait justement sur sur ce thème de
la décroissance démographique
on en a discuté et je lui ai dit
justement mes craintes à ce niveau là
mais ça n'est pas quelque chose
d'impossible ne s'hérite pas quelque
chose d'impossible mener la part très
favorable à faire venir des haïtiens par
exemple nous d'autres intérêts
américains cubain oui alors deux choses
effectivement dans
dans mon ouvrage qui viennent sortir je
parle de cela comme pistes possibles
mais à des conditions il faut que ça
rentre dans une politique globale
qu'est ce que l'on veut allonger andré
lucrèce d'une chose sur l'article de
monsieur les temps il dit ont fait venue
des haïtiens qui sont des travailleurs
disent qu'ils travaillent beaucoup pour
ça signifie par opposition le
martiniquais ne travaille pas ça moi ça
m'embête un peu cette saison non non non
alors est ce qu'on va chercher j'ai pas
en ce genre d'argument m'embête un petit
peu fleur il fait référence
essentiellement à la discipline de ces
gens là et donc non en tout cas si on
évite des gens à un micro
chez nous il faut que ces gens là un
certain nombre de qualités en toute
sécurité il y avait tous les peuples
travaillent tous les peuples sont bons
je crois qu'il nous faut éviter de faire
ce genre de comparaison je dis
simplement que s'agissant justement des
haïtiens ils ont ces qualités là ils ont
ces qualités là ce ne sont pas des
qualités qui sont partout il faut pas
non plus qu'on fasse comme aujourd'hui
l'immigration fait venir des sept lucien
et cetera pau coupé la banane beau coupé
la cale et cetera parce que les
martiniquais n'aime pas ça donc on les
fait rentrer et puis il ya une forme
d'exploitation qui s'opèrent parce
qu'ils sont taillables et corvéables à
merci
il nous faut il nous faut être face à
cette question là je pense déjà posé les
choses autrement sous l'angle de la
dignité de l'humanité et puis qu'est ce
qu'on veut pour lamartine quelle
politique migratoire politique de
développement et avec qui pour quoi
faire et on verra si on fait rentrer des
dés et puis pourquoi le point on
n'aurait pas pensé que dans le cadre de
la loi sur la diplomatie territoriales
dite loi letchimy imaginer que l'on
puisse faire de la martinique
un espace multi culturelle multi
linguiste à on a des gens qui parlent
espagnol anglais le français faire de la
martinique une terre d'expérimentation
sur un certain nombre de choses et ça ça
peut être aussi dans une relation avec
la france déterminée voilà ce que l'on
souhaite pour la martinique
dans un rapport à revisiter gepan ira
pour independence absolument pas j'ai
pas parlé de cela mais dans un rapport
avec la france a revisité qu'est ce que
l'on veut développer en martinique
quelle politique combien jusqu'à combien
de population on veut arriver
est-ce qu'on veut aller à temps à temps
parce qu'en même temps il y à nos terres
il y a nos déchets etc
qu'est ce que l'on veut est ce que ce ne
serait pas le temps de repenser pour las
martinés quelque chose pour un mieux
vivre le métier de vie comme dit
monsieur lucrèce voilà est-ce que ce
sera pas l'occasion de le faire une
piste de réflexion crucial joseph n'est
absolument pas favorable et j'étais déjà
venu en masse des jeux tous
c'est une véritable utopie que l'on
n'ouvre les frontières notamment que
l'on ait forme l'attribution de la
délivrance de visage
ce genre moi ça me paraît tout à fait
traitable je suis d'ailleurs
personnellement pour l'ouverture la plus
grande la plus large des frontières mais
que l'on imaginait minidôme à l'envers
sans paraît assez difficile
d'abord il faut se rappeler que pour
régler la question du déclin
démographique il faut quand même des
flux d'entrée relativement important
imaginez que l'on puisse gérer des
centaines et des centaines voire des
milliers de personnes venant de pays
voisins qu'on puisse les insérer ici
comme on les fait venir
on leur donne à faire quoi que va penser
le petit changement tunique est celui
qui a des velléités de s'installer comme
un de la culture qui tous pas de terre
que va-t-il pensé lorsqu'il va constater
que vous consacrer des fonds à aider d
haïti où 17 policiers etc à s'installer
en martinique etc lui
et non il n'en bénéficient pas nous
avons d'ailleurs des expériences des
deux micros expérience je vous rappelle
que si la commune de prêcheurs je ne
sais plus quelle élection présidentielle
a donné pourcentage de voix ils
reviennent
marine le pen c'est tout simplement lié
à la présence d'un huissier sur les
modes d environ 7 % rappelle pourquoi la
diviser c'était quand même oui mais là
nyala provient de vous dire que ce n'est
pas faire venir des gens comme ça c'est
josé dans un cadre politique nous sommes
ressort dans une situation où il y avait
véritablement à faire une déclaration
d'urgence l'état d'urgence et il
faudrait donc que nous entreprenions de
réformer les institutions
ces thérapies c'est possible mais à mon
avis lorsqu'on arrivera au bout de la
préparation de la mise en place de cette
solution il soit peut-être autant il
faut trouver des solutions
aujourd'hui et maintenant voilà derniers
mois andré lucrèce pour la fin de
l'émission
oui non ce que je voudrais dire qu'on
est dans la peine le temps de dire c'est
qu'il nous faut sortir simplement de
cette économie containers ccc c'est une
économie ce qu'il nous faut c'est une
économie qui crée et c'est nous ne
sommes pas là dedans de plus en plus
nous sommes dans l'économie compte 1
j'ai lu un article est paru précisément
parce que les il ya des difficultés
énormes la faire venir un certain nombre
de produits et on se demande même si les
supermarchés ne m'ont pas être dévalisés
très rapidement parce que il y a des
difficultés de transport et donc ça
montre bien que nous sommes dans une
économie contenaires et qu'il faut qu'on
en sorte
eh bien c'est ce que c'est moi que nous
allons conclure notre émission sont
partis pour trois heures de débat encore
la garantie on va revenir dessus
notre mission se termine aujourd'hui
elle a été réalisée par a dit le curé
paul eric toussaint dans quelques
instants les dernières informations avec
le journal de la rédaction de martinique
la première je vous retrouve dimanche
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
face à la première
[Musique]